foreign
[Music]
no not me you no
call him I am
that's fine then call the school I'm
calling the school he didn't have a
thing and engagement he's a kid he
doesn't have engage hi it's Frankie
mont's mum is he there
oh he isn't back yet and
permission what permission
said you gave permission
[Music]
why would you give permission I didn't
yes you did you signed they said I
didn't
all right maybe I did but you do don't
you just sign you don't read you just
click the button give permission I mean
you don't imagine that they take us on
take him where they didn't say who's
who's they they wouldn't say
well there must be someone else we can
talk to at the school the head they said
it's not their responsibility once you
give permission to a private company
nobody told me not to you're an adult
yeah and he's a child a school child
surely it's their job to protect him
isn't it yours
you're right I'm his dad and he is I
don't know where so I should uh
I should call the police I should
shouldn't I I should I should call the
police no you should have your dinner
and finish your wine oh you think no
call the police
hello please please
yeah my son is missing he he never came
home from school and um
uh yeah yeah I'll hold yoh you need to
shut up I'm dealing with this
oh yes yes uh my son's name is uh
Frankie
Frank monk m-o-n-k date of birth 5th of
February 2009. did he tell them he's 13.
you've just given the date he's 13. I
barely slept away he always said family
close friends the odd sleepover are you
mentioning his sleeper don't tell me how
to understand when this is your fault
it's not my fault this is his father's
fault he signed he gave permission
private company yes
what
they said they can't help us that
there's nothing they can do nothing but
they're the police and they're a private
company and we need to take it up with
them okay
okay fine let's take it up with them
I don't think it's appropriate to keep
the parent of a missing child on hold so
I like being on hold
it's not all my fault you know I'm sure
I'm not the only parent who gave
permission you're not
a social company I had to take a look
okay not just us hundreds and thousands
of families with missing children for an
hour a day a week a year oh well that
makes me feel better why would that make
you feel better
your parent who gave me oh yeah it's
about my son Frank Monk m-o-n
automated
option one what's option one if I've got
an issue with the service
speak to a representative
I want to speak to a representative
where you going just speak to a
representative
[Music]
this is ridiculous
it's the head office it's night time
what are you gonna do barge in there and
demand they find Frankie they won't know
who the hell he is I'll tell them he's
my kid
our son is missing his name is Frankie
Monk and I believe you and your company
are responsible and not just the Frankie
other kids and not just kids you're
responsible for all kinds of harm
alienation
polarization genocide genocide I could
go on if you like oh you could let us
through and we can find our son
[Music]
foreign
can I get you anything a tea coffee
sparkling water oh I'll have a sparkling
water please yeah when our sun is
missing
was that just regular water then thanks
foreign
thank you so remind me of his name your
son Frank monk he's 13 years old oh
that's a lovely name one moment while I
search our database
what database
uh it's a private database
the search has brought up multiple
matches
which is not unusual when you're as
popular as we are to encounter duplicate
data points
our son's not a data point
oh no you so much more than that
I'm sure
tell me are any of these your son
yeah yeah that's Frankie there
why why have you got a picture of his
bedroom it's actually a live feed so uh
the sun's not missing hurray it's been
at home the whole time you didn't check
upstairs I didn't we were rushing busy
distracted I was at home I I would have
heard him you were listening to a
podcast about the future of technology
how'd you know that why why have you got
a live feed of our son the main thing is
he's safe and entertained right now he's
speaking to Pavel on Discord what's
Discord who's Pavel you are you spying
on our son we prefer to think of it like
child care not intended to replace
existing caregivers but to uh supplement
because we understand you're busy Modern
Life is busy I'm not too busy to care
for our child too busy to correctly read
a form because you did give consent I
did not consent to this you seem to be
under the impression that we're harming
Charlie thank you Frankie in some way
yeah yeah that's my great impression
yeah okay well perhaps you'd feel
reassured by speaking to him
Frankie
why are you calling me I thought you
were downstairs
where are you at home yeah I'm in my
room I'm on my laptop what are you doing
on your laptop
I was worried I'm not
I'm not is that what you're asking Dad
we're just glad you're safe
I know
[Music]
well he was actually watching porn he
said he wasn't and I believe him and
that's your choice to turn away but uh
we prefer to see it all the boring Parts
the shameful Parts the parts that even
Frankie doesn't know about we always pay
attention always want to know
can you say the same you don't know my
son better than me actually I do all my
algorithms do see here we track his
msi's it's what his meaningful social
interactions users require regular
injections as socially derived dopamine
to maintain Optimum connection
and uh before Frankie hasn't received a
like in 15 minutes
sad face but I can boost it
there fixed your son is Happy safe and
meaningfully social what what's he doing
now
um a friend is sent to me link
of
of what
um
it's a bedding video
he's watching a beheading video sent by
a friend so technically it does still
count as a meaningful social interaction
stop it stop him watching it my job here
is to keep him watching not to tell him
what to watch so once he's clicked on
okay
okay you switched to something else what
porn
what are you doing to my child if you
are so worried about him why don't you
go to him at home because I have many
other users to support how many of these
have
watching videos of beheadings the
majority of our subscribers are
appropriately entertained ask one
huh
wouldn't that be a little bit weird a
middle-aged man speaking to her it's the
internet happens all the time what is
she doing she she's photoshopping her
body and it's been remarkable technical
know-how is our course girls creating a
fake thigh gap is not a core skill and
anyway I thought the minimum age was 13.
these children don't look 13. I can't
share data on users ages but you don't
need data you're telling me they're 13.
that user certainly skews younger it's
not a user that that's a baby still
they're happy safe and
ah I find it's just uh I think their
videos finished someone also turned off
autoplay
let me just
[Music]
see
it's still not 13. I know this might
seem disturbing because you're
exploiting children we're exploiting
their attention it's actually not the
same thing so what what next each child
gets subscribed at Birth before they're
born as a as a as a condition of
conception we have the right to grow
through optimize attention capture
children have a right to grow to be
cared for not captured or not actually
capturing children aren't you
foreign
you're scared
you're getting uh older
and the world is changing you become
more
easily confused I can see how this could
seem
alarming but the internet is safe it was
built by engineers and you know what
else was built by engineers
which is
do you worry about Bridge safety
I don't leave my child unattended on
Bridges and you don't need to leave him
unattended online either but you do even
though you know deep down don't you you
do you know that the internet is full of
misinformation misogyny racism fascism
pro-anorexia Pro self-harm anti-truth
antinuance anti-empathy toxic propaganda
or as we like to call it engaging
content
well if you know that it's that bad
why don't you do something to fix it how
turn off auto play get rid of infinite
scroll surveillance capitalism extreme
material oh yeah that'd be good and
everyone will be happy and safe all of
the time
no
harm is inevitable offline and on so
that's a reason to not even try I don't
see you trying to change the world
either
see you online
actually
[Music]
you won't
sorry I seem to have spilled my water
can I get another one
sparkling this time
[Music]
oh hey is the internet down I was just
on it then it went out
[Music]
it's good to have you back but I've been
here all this time still
it's good to have you back
wait let me
[Music]
foreign